you definitely must have had an oral  rehydration solution ors when you got  sick and were feeling weak why weren't  you able to distinguish between the  sugar and the salt in the water as you  may have guessed correctly it's a  solution a solution is a homogeneous  mixture composed of two or more  substances so we cannot visually  distinguish between its components the  substance which is to be dissolved is  called the solute and the medium in  which it is dissolved is called the  solvent sugar and salt in the ors are  solutes while water is the solvent given  the particles are dissolved so well in  the solvent the particles of the  solution cannot scatter a beam of light  can you tell us what the solution is  called when the solvent is water if you  like the video do share it and subscribe  to the channel for more scientific  updates  [Music]